Today, young men and women are taking different
paths into adulthood, arranging school, work
and family in a dizzying array of combinations.
Amidst all these options there's one path
for today's young adults that's more likely
to steer them clear of poverty and towards
the American dream.
In a new report, Wendy Wang and I find that
Millennials who took three simple steps as
part of what's called The Success Sequence
are much more likely to be doing well.
In fact, 97% of young adults who, 1), got
at least a high school degree and, 2), held
down a full time job, and, 3), got married
before having any children avoided poverty
by the time they hit their early 30s.
And, 86% of them are in the middle or upper
end of the income distribution.
The Success Sequence is also associated with
markably better economic outcomes for minorities
and young adults from poor families.
The bottom line: it sure looks like The Success
Sequence is a durable path towards the American
dream.
To learn more about my take on the Millennial
Success Sequence, check the links in the description
below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want
AEI Scholars to cover in 60 seconds.